you know
policies have consequences and the
quality of life in america's big cities
is so bad that it's
it is surpassing the ability of
partisanship to submit or hide the truth
because democrats are fed up with these
policies look no further than los
angeles it's plagued by crime filth and
rampant homelessness and that's
according to its former
mayor antonio villarresa blaming his
successor saying i have never seen this
town so dirty i have never seen crime up
so quickly the spread of homelessness i
think to many rome is burning
new york is burning too but the city
council here has other priorities like
removing a statue of thomas jefferson
and declaring racism a public health
crisis joining me now to break down this
lunacy
these policies is brit hume fox news
senior political analyst brett i guess
we can rest easy that the new york
politicians have their priorities in the
right place murder up jefferson statues
down
that's the idea this is a this you know
this civil rights movement was a great
movement at one time
it was about tearing down barriers and
now
took much of the time and is about
tearing down statues doing that tearing
down a statue or moving it out of sight
or whatever they want to do is not going
to change the life of one kid in in
harlem or new york or anywhere else
these are empty gestures designed to fan
the flames of racial uh disagreement in
this country
and and it's all about when you get down
to it well you were so right throughout
most of this broadcast it is about the
collapse of
of individual responsibility which was
something that has been integral to
america's growth and prosperity and now
we see
people in a situation where the
criminals are not really to blame it's
the police force um and you know crimes
go unpunished unarrested uh you have you
know people walking out of walgreens
stores in san francisco with tons of
material and selling it on the street
and all that unpunished
personal responsibility
is not the order of the day you know
britt as i was listening to you i
started thinking about this and i think
i want to talk about this later this
week on fox news prime primetime but
these rolling state of emergencies i
don't know how many states now are
living under a state of emergency most
because of covey but to see the new york
politicians declare racism a public
health crisis it's not just a reflection
of their priorities but increasingly it
will be a power center source for them
if it's an emergency yeah then all
measures are are worthwhile
and that's right and and the truth of
the matter is that that what these these
politicians are doing they're exploiting
really the decency of the decency of the
american people which responded to to
the situation in this country where
racism was much too prevalent and
persisted long after the slave slaves
were freed and america as a nation stood
up took notice of that and made major
major changes
which have opened doors of opportunity
throughout the land
uh throughout society really and it
changed
and it touched the conscience of a
nation
americans don't believe racism a
terrible thing and being called a racist
is one of the worst things that can
happen but it has become a source of
power for unscrupulous politicians who
have exploited it ever since and
continue to and by keeping the issue
alive
they keep a source of power for
themselves alive and they keep the
decline of american cities in a
perpetual state of tragedy murder crime
homelessness all on the rise while they
they battle this this don quixote
windmill of accumulating more power for
themselves brad i think it's the first
time we've talked i hope it's not the
last thank you for being on hope so too
will nice to see you you too hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else